all right despite the endless media
chatter about FBI raids and porn star
payments there are actually far more
important stories that are simply being
ignored by the mainstream media and by
the way they're the ones that most
affect the American people so in spite
of all the sideshow drama I have to tell
you tonight President Trump is getting
real results by largely following his
instincts think about it on the
immigration front when all the others
were afraid well Trump called for
serious border enforcement and he named
the threats facing the United States we
will end the sanctuary cities that have
resulted in so many needless deaths it
is the policy of this administration to
dismantle decimate and eradicate ms-13
at Old Mexico very strongly you're gonna
have to do something about these
caravans that are coming Oh what became
of that Isle Caravan well that Caravan
was largely dispersed and whatever
stragglers make it to our border well
they'll be greeted by our friendly
members of the National Guard
then there was North Korea well the
pundit class attacked President Trump
for daring to threaten Rocketman with
fire and fury if in fact Kim jong-un
persisted with his nuclear ambitions
well now North Korea is at the
negotiating table and willing to discuss
denuclearization winning and remember
the chorus of naysayers that greeted
Trump's announcement to slap tough new
tariffs on China China is hitting back
after President Trump appeared to raise
the second I'm sorry it's such a
surprise we would be put in this
terrible position simply saying jobs
jobs jobs is about as convincing as
trade wars are good and easy to win how
dangerous is it that the person who's
negotiating this has his facts day in
day out wrong and the person I'm talking
about mr. president is you it's much
more persuasive when you do that in the
camera well China is now blinking on
trade thank you very much
and president gee just announced that
China is going to be lowering tariffs on
auto imports including those from the
United States he also promised to
protect the intellectual property of
those doing business in China now why
would he be making such sweeping changes
huh I wonder president Trump's political
instincts let's face it they're really
good but there are two major forces
seeking to frustrate that instinct first
Congress now it was congressional
leaders who lash the president over
those proposed China tariffs they also
refused to fund his border wall in fact
they misled him on the border wall
they're the same people who railroaded
the president into that 1.3 trillion
dollar fiasco of omnibus spending bill
remember that last day his instinct was
to veto the bill but under pressure from
congressional leaders the generals and
the military-industrial complex well he
signed it they sold this bill of goods
to the president with the promise that
it was going to bolster the military
which it does and protect the country
but now the president has buyer's
remorse I say to Congress I will never
sign another bill like this again to
prevent the omnibus situation from ever
happening again I'm calling on Congress
to give me a line-item veto for all
government spending bills well I have a
question here how does mounting debt in
rising deficits make us stronger how
does that make America great again it
doesn't and now even the GOP leaders who
created this funding nightmare are
looking to pass a few I don't know show
votes to demonstrate how fiscally
responsible they are before
the midterms oh that's gonna work well
the other force the second force
frustrating the president's instinct is
the war Lobby he is now being dragged
back into a conflict in Syria which is a
dangerous complex international
situation fraught with trouble Assad is
certainly a vicious horrible dictator
and the civil war there has cost
hundreds of thousands of lives but he
also helped wipe out Isis and he is
protecting the Christian minority in
Syria no doubt about that
Assad is aided and protected also by
Iran and Russia further complicating
matters so any military action even
targeted limited airstrikes they can
lead to unintended consequences an
international conflict that we cannot
predict from this point dragging us into
another desert war it's not what the
president campaigned on in fact he ran
against military adventurism in the
Middle East in my opinion we've spent
four trillion dollars trying to topple
various people that frankly if they were
there and if we could have spent that
four trillion dollars in the United
States to fix our roads our bridges and
all of the other problems our airports
and all of the other problems we have we
would have been a lot better off I can
tell you that right now we have done a
tremendous disservice not only to the
Middle East we've done a tremendous
disservice to humanity the people that
have been killed
the people that have been wiped away and
for what it's not like we had victory
the president is most successful when he
sticks to his conservative populist
instincts even when he was assaulted by
the bush Graham McCain establishment he
did the right thing and why because the
people were with him part of the reason
why he won this election it's a major
reason why he won this election he's
also best when he follows his political
instincts those raw political instincts
that he has and he's not talked
the things by card-carrying members of
the swamp who despise his agenda every
time he lets the swamp lead disaster
follows
so my advice tonight to the president
stick to your agenda
do not let investigations or Congress
derail it or distract you and a time
when your numbers are up near fifty
percent in Congress's their cratering
you should be giving them advice not the
other way around and that's the angle